the upcoming winter games could make
history by featuring North and South
Korea's first unified Olympic team the
two Koreas agreed in principle to join
to a joint women's hockey team in
Pyeongchang
South Korea's team currently includes
five players who were born in South
Korea but raised in other countries so
how's that work one of them is 24 year
old Marissa Brandt who was adopted as an
infant by a Minnesota family Dana
Jacobson spoke with Brent about what a
United Korean team could mean what's it
like knowing though that you could
possibly be a part of something that is
bigger than sport and it would be
historic you know just the tension
between North and South Korea it's it's
so high and even just a little small
thing like this of showing that we can
be unified would just I hope go a long
way her 24 year old sister Hanna
she's also going to the Olympics she
plays for the American hockey team Dana
Jacobson will bring us more of the
sister story next month I'm already
curious about how that's going to work
this I liked it I did like it too